la journée s'achève on sent qu'elle a
été longue pour yoon-kyung c'est elle
qui avait ouvert ce qu'a fait ce matin
qui l'employeur à réaménager les
horaires pour réduire les coûts dit elle
il y a moins de clients s'étant de
covile 19 ses collègues à temps partiel
en pâtissent près de deux cent mille
personnes ont perdu leur emploi en mars
la plus importante baisse enregistrée
dans le pays en une décennie et plus
d'un million de sud coréennes ne sont
plus payés même s'ils n'ont pas été
renvoyés en principe il s'attend à une
hausse de faillite personnelle dans ce
pays où l'endettement des ménages est
astronomique
le gouvernement sud-coréen a annoncé
divers programmes dead à coup de
dizaines de milliards de dollars
les pandémies touche durement les petits
commerces
la plupart n'ont pas les reins assez
solides face à la crise
kim dong keun en sait quelque chose
c'est afin n'était déjà pas très bonne
avant la pandémie
mais là il est dans le rouge il explique
que les gens en route pour le bureau ou
la maison le secteur de plus dans son
petit espace pour chiner pour tâter la
marchandise en encourageant la
distanciation sociale bien des
entreprises ont notamment opter pour le
télétravail et en déployant les grands
moyens contre l'épidémie
comme le dépistage massif la corée du
sud a pu maîtriser la propagation de
lakovic 19 sans avoir à ordonner la
fermeture de l'activité économique
comme ce fut le cas notamment en europe
et en amérique du nord le professeur
dimitri chez pierrot souligne que
l'économie a connu une contraction moins
importante que celle d'autres pays en
asie grâce au maintien de la demande
pour les semi conducteurs
mais il croit qu'il sera difficile
d'éviter une récession si la
consommation poursuit sa glissade
même chose pour les exportations au
moment où bien des partenaires de la
corée du sud sont aux prises avec la
pandémie ici annick bureaud radio canada
et vous